all right thank you everybody for day
two of pi data global uh appreciate you
joining us uh we have meredith luff who
is going to speak on from jupiter
notebook to production web app with
anvil and only python uh unsurprisingly
uh works for anvil so we're happy to
have anvil with us presenting
um
and i'm happy to hand it over and let
you take it away
awesome well thank you very much
uh my name is meredith and i am here to
talk today about deployment
so
deployment
is
the gentle art of taking something that
works and turning it into something
that's actually useful
so
as
data people generally speaking we are in
the business of answering questions with
data
and
some of those questions are exploratory
one-offs and we can answer them by
sending an email
but many of them aren't one-offs we know
that some variant of that question is
going to be asked again and again and
again and so we want to automate
now if it's a human asking the question
then really ideally we would want some
sort of user interface self-service so
they can do it themselves
and uh our best bet there is a web
application
so they can open it in their browser uh
and get on with it
uh so uh building a web application that
means building a user interface in html
and uh doing uh making it to
behave with javascript styling it with
css
uh probably building like a flask back
end and then plumbing it all together
with react and redux and bootstrap and
webpack and docker and git and i'm
excited are you excited
i didn't think so
so today what i'm going to talk to you
about is how we can skip getting bogged
down
by
doing all of that entirely in python
so i'm going to show you
uh how to build a web application with a
framework called anvil
which allows us to build sophisticated
web applications uh without having to
know any javascript uh no front-end web
experience required you don't even
really need to do about web back-ends
you can build something fairly
sophisticated with just some pretty
basic python
so let's let's set the scene
we have been tasked
with
a strategically vital
data question
which is
to tell the difference between
photographs of dogs and cats
and in fact we have already succeeded we
something that works
and uh like many a data scientist we
have done this in a jupiter notebook so
let's take a look
uh so
uh
this happens to be a neural network uh
but the point is we've solved this
problem you don't really need to think
too much about what exactly we're doing
here the important part is that we
actually have a function that we can
give an image to and it will give us
some a score
a guess of what category that image
falls into
and we have some sample code to drive it
so we can here is some code that loads
an image from the file system
and
gets a prediction score and then prints
the classification
if we run it
we can see it does in fact work
so
we have presented this to the strategic
animal identification group we have got
a standing ovation and frankly ever
since they've been breathing down our
necks to say when can we actually use
this
now unfortunately we can't just hand
them this because
this is an interface where we write
source code and click run and they need
a user interface if they want to drive
it themselves
so let's look at creating a user
interface in python
so to do this i'm going to open up the
anvil editor and what you're looking at
here is a web page
and over here is a toolbox of things i
can put onto that web page
so
i can
put a title onto this page by dragging
and dropping a link component into the
title bar and then i can change its
properties so i can say it's text is
hello pi data global
okay let's be a little bit more
interactive i want to make like a hello
world application
that prompts the user
to enter their name
and then when they enter it we're going
to display a greeting
so we're going to want a text box for
them to put that data into i'm going to
call this name box
everything in andrew has a variable name
so we can access it from code
and i'm going to add a button
that you can click when they're done
we can make that a little bit more
prominent
you can see what's going to happen here
they're going to enter their name uh
click the button
and
we're going to display a greeting so
here is the label for that message to
appear on i'm going to call it message
label and we can change some other
properties as well we can make it
centered and we can make it big and so
on
so oh
just move that around where i shouldn't
have
so we've built
a user interface we didn't have to touch
any html or javascript
in fact it's all backed by python so if
i double click this button
i am actually editing the python code
that runs when this button gets clicked
and you can see that let's zoom in a
little bit so you can see a bit better
oh not that far
you can see that all the things i have
added to
my page are available as objects in my
python code so if i want to set the text
on this message label based on the text
that was in the name box i can go
self.messagelabel.txt equals hello and
then let's go self.namebox.com
and if we run this
and i try entering my name
oh
i think i zoomed zoomed in too much to
get my there we go get my syntax right
self.namebox.txt that's right
okay try that again
enter my name
and we've built an
interactive uh user interface entirely
in python
we can actually put this on the web so i
choose a url for it uh say hello pi data
global
amble.map and now we can open this
and see the user interface we've just
built
so let's take a step and uh
show you what's just happened there so
this python code we've written actually
runs in the web browser
so
when somebody opens up their laptop and
types hello pi data global that amazon
app into the web browser
they will load the application we've
just written and it will run in the web
browser on their laptop and so when they
click that button the button one click
function is running
in the browser on their laptop which is
great for building some user interfaces
but
we're looking to crunch some data here
and uh we don't really want to
ship sort of huge data sets out to the
out to the browser we don't want to be
trying to run pandas uh
in inside the browser we would really
like to run in a proper python
environment uh on the server
so let's see how to do that
so you can do this in android by adding
a server module this is a python module
that runs on the server
uh
so i'm going to make a function called
say hello
and it's going to return
hello from the server
name
hey meredith
all right so
this is a server module this is a
this is a python module that's running
on the server and i've just written
a function but what we can do is we can
tag this function anvil.server.callable
and that means that we can call this
function on the server from our user
interface
so let's go back to our user interface
and
instead of computing this message here
in the web browser instead we can
amble.server.call that sayhello
function and now
it wants
a name argument so we can pass in the
text from that name box
and when we run this
we can see it's saying hello from the
server
so
what we've done here
is we've defined
a function say hello that's running on
the server side
and when that when we run that button
one click function it calls that
function on the server so it passes some
data over
uh to the server does some computation
on the server and then passes a result
back
now here we're really cooking because we
are no longer executing in some
uh
subrestricted browser environment we are
running in a proper python environment
with all of the goodies from the python
ecosystem we have come to know and love
so as a simple demonstration let's do a
tiny bit of natural language processing
on the name so i'm going to use the
python library which is a python
hyphenation library to guess at where we
can put line breaks into a word
so
i'm going to
go back to my server module
and i am going to
import
the python module
and then when we call this function well
let's initialize python with
english language
and instead of the straight name we're
going to ask python to
to insert all the hyphens it knows how
to insert into that name
so
let's let's see how it copes with my
name
it copes terribly with my name well i
mean that's that that's kind of allowed
we asked it for english not welsh let's
try a colleague
see how it does with patricia's name
much nicer okay there's a reasonable
word breaks
and so what we've done is because we've
taken this data to the server and we're
doing the computation there we can now
uh bring all of the usual python
ecosystem to bear which is pretty cool
but let's go back to the original task
we started with because
we
have some we have something a little bit
more complex to do than
just using a hyphenation module and in
fact we've already done it we've got a
jupyter notebook working here so can we
just hook this up
well the answer is actually yes we can
using something called the uplink
so
this is a way to take python code that's
running anywhere in the world
and connect it to our anvil application
and what this means is that we can
define functions in our jupyter notebook
and then
call them
from the user interface just like we saw
with server functions and pass data in
and pass data back so we can build the
user interface interface on top of the
stuff that's already working
let's let's show that in action so
we the first thing we want to do is to
connect our jupyter notebook to this
application we've just built so we want
to add the uplink
to our application
and enable it
so
what this means is it's given us an
authentic what it's done it's given us
an authentication token
and once we've installed the andal
uplink library we can use that token to
connect to our app so let's do that
let's pick install the library
tada
and then let's connect
oh no
apparently my copy paste game is weak
today
that's better okay so we have connected
so now
in this jupyter notebook we can write an
anvil server server callable function
say hello let's call it say hello j for
jupiter
uh say print
greeting
name and then we can return
hello from jupiter
and the name
so
this function is now in our notebook and
ready to call
so if we go back to our user interface
over here
instead of say hello we're going to call
say hello j
and when we run it
spell my own name right
it's saying hello from jupiter
and if we go into the output here we can
see the print statement so it really is
running in this cell in our jupyter
notebook
so let's take stock
we now have
a working jupiter notebook we have
solved our critical business problem
we have a way to build a front end
entirely in python without having to
know any javascript
and we have a way to connect them and
make them work together
so
we have everything we need start your
stopwatches it's time to deploy so i'm
going to build a user interface on top
of
our cat versus dog classifier i'm going
to start from scratch we need to build a
might as well build a new app
so what we're going to have is a web
application where you can upload a photo
and it will tell you what the model
thought of it so put some title in here
cat or door
uh
put a card on here to look a bit nice
okay so we want them to be able to
upload a file so i'm going to use the
file loader component
and then we need to display the results
so i'm going to put in a result a label
here to display the results i'm going to
call it result label
and we can change some more text
properties we can make it bold and we
can make it big
let's also display the input image so
i'm going to take an image component and
put it next to the result label
and then i'm going to make them line up
a little bit more nicely i'm going to
put a spacer in here and adjust its
height there we go so the result lines
up nicely
oh
no not that come on
there we go
so
i've just built a user interface time to
connect it to my jupyter notebook
we know how to do this we add the uplink
to our application we enable it
we get our authentication token and then
we go to jupiter
and we connect
so we're now connected in our notebook
to that application
we could now write a callable function
that
invokes the code we've already written
in our jupyter notebook so we'll call it
predict it's going to do prediction from
our model it's going to be passed in an
image we can just pass in binary data to
functions that's not a problem
uh
so this image is going to arrive as an
anvil media object
so
i'm going to import a library i can use
to write that as a temporary file
and we'll got media so to get a
temporary file
and
then we can you we can do just what we
did
uh above in our sample code we can load
the image into pillow
the standard way and then we can
get a prediction from our model from
that image
to get a numerical score
and now all we need to do is return
something back to the user interface so
let's return see cats
if the score is greater than 0.5 else
dog
and let's return the numerical score as
well
so we've defined this function in our
jupyter notebook and it's sitting there
ready to call
so the last thing we need is to wire up
the user interface so
when somebody
uploads a file into this user interface
well we'll we will want to analyze
server.call that predict function
and we want to pass it as an argument
that file that they've uploaded again we
can just pass passes media as an
argument and we'll take care of that
and then of course this will return our
results so it will return a
classification and it will also return
the score
so we want to display that
on the results label so we say results
book
the result label dot text
equals well we want the classification
obviously
and then in brackets let's put the score
let's format it to two decimal places
and then let's display the input image
as well so we take that image component
we set its source
to be again the file that was uploaded
so let's run it
i'm going to upload an image
pick a cat
and there we have it
we have built a working user interface
that allows us to use the thing that was
already working
so we have a predict function
that's running over here on the jupiter
notebook and the file loader change
function can call it passing in the
image data do some computation in our
notebook and pass back a result
we're almost ready to publish actually
but but not quite because this remember
is a critically important proprietary
model and we don't want to expose it to
just anybody on the internet we probably
want to only allow authorized users
conveniently anvil has built-in user
authentication so we can add this to our
app as well
so
it supports a whole bunch of ways to
authenticate including your classic
username and password but if we're in a
corporate environment we're probably
using some form of single sign-on so uh
we happen to be a g suite shop so we'll
use google sign-in but you could very
easily use uh you know microsoft azure
or octa or whatever it is you use in
your environment
let's go to the bottom and add one
account from the reddit anvil.works
and enable it
so now let's go back to our jupiter
notebook because this function here
is
our our crown jewels
we don't want just anybody
to be able to invoke it this is the
thing we want to protect so what we can
do is we can specify require user equals
true
and that what that means is that this
function will only execute if
it's being called by someone who has
logged into your application
successfully
so let's demonstrate it by running
without logging in
i'm just going to upload a random cat
and what do you know authentication
failed you must be logged in it has
refused to run because i haven't logged
in
so let's
complete the loop and actually log in so
here we're back in our user interface
this is the init method so this is the
code that runs when the page opens and
we can call amble.users
users.login with form
to
pull up a
prebuilt login form
it's going to ask me to sign in with
google i'm going to prove that i am
who i say i am
that should have worked try again
sign in prove that i am who i say i am
that's better okay
upload an image
and what do you know
so i have now proved that i am an
authorized user and because of that it
is allowing me to invoke this model
and use this user interface we've built
so we really have deployed our model
here we have taken something that was
already working
as jupiter notebook and we've turned it
into something that the strategic animal
identification team can use
even though they're not comfortable
typing python code
obviously there's an awful lot more i
could do here for example i could move
that code from the jupyter notebook
into
the
into the server side code so i can shut
down my notebook
or i could do an awful lot more uh so we
haven't even talked about um
creating pdfs or running scheduled jobs
or sending and receiving emails but
suffice it to say that if you want to
generate a pdf report at 4pm every
friday and email it out to everyone you
can do that
you can do a bunch more uh this is a
full-featured web framework
so here is a university in mongolia
with a who's created a dashboard to
track air pollution in ulaanbaatar
uh it's not just dashboards uh this is a
software as a service platform so this
is lightning ai an ad tech company that
was unsurprisingly founded by a data
scientist with their user interface and
whole account management system built
with anvil
and
if you happen to be joining us from
germany switzerland or austria next time
you go to the bakery and buy some bread
check behind the counter perhaps the
entire bakery you're using
from the first doe to the point of sale
will actually be running with a
predictive management system built with
anvil you have an egg
you can find out more at anvil.works
there are a bunch of tutorials and
examples uh you can use it for free
everything i've been doing today is
available on the free plan and of course
it's an open source framework so you can
clone it from github or pip install it
and run your applications locally that's
all going to work
you can also talk to me
i am naturally on the conference slack
or you can drop me an email
therefore.works or you can get in touch
via the website
i hope you have enjoyed this little tour
through deployment ville and that i've
given you something to think about next
time you have something that works and
you need to turn it into something
useful thank you very much
awesome yeah thank you thank you very
much uh we do have some questions in
both uh the q a uh
uh window as well as the chat uh i don't
know if you want me to just awesome if
you can read them out that would be
great because of the way i'm screen
sharing you can't see them from here
yeah so um i'll just maybe start from
the top uh the one question is uh what
is the technology you're using for
running the python code in the browser
oh my goodness okay it's called sculpt
skulpt.org
uh it's an open source project i'm one
of the maintainers i can talk about it
all day um
it's so it's a python javascript
compiler uh so what what actually
happens is that when you write that
python code in your user interface we
compile it to javascript and we run it
in the web browser
when it opens but it really is running
in your web browser
um another question uh can you have the
callable in your notebook return some
richer outputs plots images etc oh yes
absolutely um there is full-on plotly
support so you can return like a whole
you could return a properly plot object
and produce an interactive plot on the
client side
or there are actually tutorials i'm i
think i've already linked to them in
slack if not i'm about to post a link to
them in skype as soon as this is this uh
session is over um with tutorials for
how to use like you know how to return
like a matplotlib plot but absolutely
just like you could return you could
send rich data like uploaded files into
your notebook you could absolutely send
rich data back out again
all right um this question
uh comparing like anvil to like heroku
or uh steamlift uh streamlabs right um
if do they do the same is there a
difference that you would highlight so
the thing about heroku
is
it
if you sort of if you thought about that
list of technologies i was i was talking
about you know for creating a
traditional web application heroku does
help you with like the stuff that you
know docker and aws and what have you
but you still need to build a full-on
web application
uh so you're still having to deal with
all of the complexities of the framework
uh streamli is i mean i'm not gonna lie
streamline it's pretty cool uh streamlit
is sort of more of a get something
simple up there and less of an
application package
so
uh
you could do some of these things with
streamlit but the thing you probably
couldn't do with screenlit is scale that
from hey this is my first prototype in a
jupyter notebook up to hey this is my
production user interface
it's just anvil has an awful lot more
richness as an application framework
great all right um so we uh had this uh
uh someone was mentioning that they are
exploring a solution like this for
serving an app in the organization uh
where i can store the code in a get lab
repo use yep server gcp to put uh or to
be able to run python code in the back
end is anvil something that could
support this scenario uh
short answer yes long answer yes uh
so yes uh absolutely if you want to host
in on a machine in gcp like pip install
apple app server
git clone your application just launch
it it's you know it's an open source web
framework
what do you want um
you can
integrate with development environment a
couple of ways
so
every anvil application is in fact a git
repository so if you're using the cloud
hosted editor which i was in the demo
just now
then you can
then you can you can integrate with that
because it's just a git repository uh or
you can get if you want your source code
to stay
out of uh the editor then you can get
non-site enterprise installation
depending on your requirements but yes
absolutely there are several different
ways that uh that that particular
arrangement would work with anvil uh
ping me on slack if you want more
details
okay awesome uh next question was uh uh
is this going to put a lot of traffic
through the notebook server
uh so uh yes if you're doing if you're
doing your computation in the notebook
then yeah it's
your all the computation is happening in
the notebook if you would like to move
that computation out of your notebook
then
you can move that python code into this
into a server module and then you can
run it in anvil's backend or you can
we have tutorials for sort of taking
that and packaging it up and running it
from a slightly beefier server that can
cope with the load uh but yes the the
point of what we were doing here
was to
bring the data to where you've already
got the computation working if you want
to move the computation somewhere else
that absolutely works as well it's just
by nothing magic
okay uh next question uh do you have
metrics uh from a production environment
where an app has been deployed and
served uh an apple server what about
memory contention in the server side
uh
memory contention i mean so i'm i'm
gonna go need a little bit more specific
i mean that the short answer is that yes
there are some fairly large applications
out there using anvil i don't know
what about memory contention you wanted
to
to know i am very happy to talk about
like running apps in production and how
that works uh but yeah i just need a
little bit more details about what
question they were asking okay um uh
wondering if the self-hosted version of
this has the same features as the anvil
hosted one
so the uh
the
anvil hosted environment or the hat
includes the editor
uh and
uh that you know you you can also get
that on site uh but the app server is a
you know is a standalone server because
typically that's what we see people want
you know they want they build their
application and then they want the thing
that they can stick into a docker
container and feed into their uh their
devops process or whatever uh so
the but the runtime environment that we
are using is like on the hosted service
at amazon.works is exactly the same
runtime as the runtime library as you'll
get if you
clone our git repository
we've got some extra infrastructure
around there around running like a
multi-tenanted hosting hosting
environment but the actual runtime stuff
is the same all the features in your app
will work in both places
very good uh next question if you are
running your prediction function from a
jupyter notebook does that mean you need
to have a running jupiter server to
execute that function
if you terminate that jupiter server do
you end up preventing anvil from running
your prediction
function
that yeah that's exactly right so let me
let me let me pull up the the slide
where where we talked about this
so this is the topology of what we ended
up with at the at the end of this talk
so the predict function is running in
jupiter and the data is going to jupiter
so yes if you kill your jupiter notebook
at this point then
uh your then you won't be able to run
the prediction function so
if you want to be able to shut down your
jupyter notebook the thing you want to
do is to move your prediction function
up into
the
server code which is a fairly
straightforward matter of you know
pasting that python code into one of
those server modules honestly the only
reason i didn't demonstrate that today
is because i didn't have time in this
talk it's it's not a very difficult
process we also by the way uh have a
couple of tutorials on the website if
you don't want to do that if you if you
have some specific resources say you
wanted to you know execute on a machine
with a bunch of gpus we also have some
tutorials for taking a jupiter notebook
and turning it into something you can
deploy out on a virtual server somewhere
so it will stay running when you close
your laptop
very good um someone's wondering if you
could uh speak to hipaa compliance if
applicable
uh so
the short answer is if you're doing
something like that you will probably
want an on-site installation whether
you're using the app server or the um or
an animal enterprise installation uh
if you need a yes uh
audits would probably have to be run on
one of those uh again play me on slack
uh an experience with workflows where
the code was written in jupyter notebook
and made available in a production
environment what a follow-up question
what about testing logging code review
and other steps before code makes it to
production
so okay so
uh that was a lot of questions in one so
due to notebook to a production
environment so typically i mean again
people people use the word production to
mean a bunch of different things uh if
you're talking about the kind of kind of
production environment that's sort of
heavy on the code of you and so on at
that point you've probably done
something you you've probably migrated
some of that code out of a jupiter
notebook into either a standalone
service using the up link or into an
annual server module
so there's a
one of the screenshots i didn't include
in the little section earlier is a
company called eve data that does a
bunch of retail data processing and and
they have very much that pro that kind
of process so uh they they they code
review the sort of the micro service
that runs their ram
uh runs their data processing pipeline
separately outside of anvil actually
lightning ai do something similar uh
but if you're if you're talking about
code inside handle so if you're using
your server modules to deploy uh your
code
then uh that kind of code review and
version control happens within the anvil
editor so if you
uh if i just switched over here i can
actually pop up the version history here
so uh there is in fact a full access to
the git repository let's move up here
full access to the git repository that
is backing this application and you can
have like you can create some staging
environments to deploy and test into uh
you can drive this with ci systems uh
people yeah you can do some of your code
review before you merge that sort of
thing
and yes we have people doing that in
production
awesome well thank you very much i'm
gonna hit stop now